[Musique]
la commune de trois-bassins signe son
pacte de solidarité territoriale deux
millions deux cent vingt-six mille euros
seront attribués par le département pour
la partie investissement
ils financeront des travaux
d'aménagement comme ici sur le chemin
des bassins pour la sécurisation des
radiés ces fonds permettront également
le développement d'équipements de
proximité la modernisation du réseau
d'eau potable et d'électricité
ça va nous permettre de faire la visite
de les radier l'aménagement
le serrage et et bien sûr les
investissements qui a un côté il ya bien
sûr le volet social avec le ccas le
pontage de repas à domicile et aussi
l'accompagnement conduire 227 mille
euros dead seront attribués au secteur
social
le département souhaite par ce
dispositif conforter ses actions de
proximité préserver l'autonomie des
personnes âgées en fait partie avec
notamment le financement de portage de
repas à domicile
l'humain salle principale on perd mais
là j'ai le territoire mais on le fait au
service de la population et je suis
heureux de voir que elle est là elle
avec sa famille elle est bonne humeur et
leur bonne santé dont baby soit elle
bonne santé bravo et merci encore à face
à la réunion la réunion que nous ou
scénarii nous la voilà nous y sommes
cinq rayons avec nos gramounes toujours
en bonne santé de bonne humeur il faut
pas que les jours il faut l'assumer
le président du département s'est
ensuite rendu dans la commune de la
possession qui à son tour signe son
pacte de solidarité territoriale
plus de deux millions d'euros
d'investissements et 227 mille euros
fonctionnement seront mises à
disposition par le département pour
soutenir les projets de proximité porté
par la commune des projets d'aménagement
par exemple de parcs de loisirs sur
moulin joli
aussi de maisons créatif surfeurs de
ville sur des réhabilitations dans les
écoles notamment depuis une centrale et
ensuite sur tous les projets qui sont
plutôt d'ordre social avec l'aide au
permis pour les jeunes avec de
l'accompagnement de nos adolescents pour
l'intégration de toutes les communautés
qui vivent à la procession dans son
volet social le pacte de solidarité
territoriale soutien l'insertion
professionnelle de la jeunesse
chaque commune portent des actions
innovantes en faveur de la population
des mesures qui peuvent émerger grâce au
financement du pacte de solidarité
territoriale et je vois apparaître des
projets tellement innovant que ça me
fait plaisir
et bien sûr ça ce que ce qui est le voir
la possession peut servir au reste ce
qui a été à sainte-suzanne au 1 ce matin
à trois bassins va ça vient aussi au
résumé rite war c'est ça l'esprit du
parc de solidarité faire émerger des
projets qui viennent du territoire le
territoire le plus près le territoire
communal
les quartiers et à partir de ces projets
pouvoir les développer
je m'en sens de la vie
[Musique]